Natalie?
Morning, Mr. Cobb.
Look, I'm gonna need to rearrange some meetings for today, free up some time midday.
You've got meetings midday.
I've got meetings all day.
Yeah.
Maybe we can move this 1 o'clock to 5.
There's a meeting at 5.
But, I'm gonna need some time for lunch at some point.
What sort of lunch?
What?
What sort of lunch do you like?
I'll set up a meeting to discuss lunch options.
I don't want a meeting, I want to eat at 1 o'clock.
You've got a meeting at 1 o'clock.
I know I've got...
What is this one o'clock?
Boardroom availability.
What's that?
It's a meeting to discuss the availability of the boardrooms.
Availability for?
Meetings.
Right, so this is a meeting to discuss having a meeting.
No, that's at 4 p.m.
Right, let's strip some of this out.
Let's get rid of that boardroom meeting thing,...
...the conference call, and definitely the visits to the toilet.
That'll give me some time.
Who are you calling?
Heads of department.
Emergency meeting to discuss the rearrangement of your meeting schedule.
I'll pick out the afternoon.